how much fun was it putting this look
together for the amas oh so much fun I
kept saying to my Gmail
[Music]
of approval from the team when you
walked out the door oh yeah I mean my
team and I are like we spend so much
time together we're besties let's crush
it though thank you thank you oh
congratulations you know I think people
think it's easy to make the jump from TV
and specifically Disney to what you're
doing now and here you are at the amas
nominee for best new artists of the year
how does it feel
yeah I mean I think like like um I don't
know I think the the number one remark
that we keep making is like if somebody
had told me that this is how the year
was going to go at the top of the year
I'd be like like that's not how time
works there's no way you could make that
leap that quickly like it just kind of
feels like this amazing lucky
Whirlwind and I feel like I I have to
think like definitely like the the queer
Community for embracing these so
wholeheartedly and just I mean everybody
for for really sticking with me as I you
know make what it probably looks like a
very drastic transition but but feels
more myself than ever I know it's a
labor of love and also you know you just
want to put out the work you can't
control the rest of it but it must feel
nice you know and now you get to perform
here for the first time any nerves you
you know I think I had some but I I tend
to kind of think like
this is really morbid but like
you know I think the way that I calm my
nerves is like knowing that how short
everything is like I'm only gonna be
alive for a certain amount of time like
you know it's the amas it's huge it's
amazing these moments are so you're
gonna think about them forever and also
life is like so fast so you have to
enjoy it that kind of yeah that kind of
melts my nerves a little knowing that no
you got to just jump right in right we
only got One Life to Live and you're at
the amas baby
really crazy
um so your new single bad idea already a
Bop but I know it was inspired by a text
that you got what was the text of we
gotta know you
the first person to ask that is yeah
um I can't say but you know it was like
I feel like everybody's been in that
situation where you get a text from an
ex who's like I miss you so much like
it's all still it feels the same for me
and you're like no I've grown from this
like yeah you're like I've done the work
I'm Healed yeah you're like I'm actually
field but then there's like that little
voice where you're like
is this like the best bad idea that I'm
gonna have you know what I mean like
yeah honey honey we've all been there a
few times
um but yeah I can't I can't tell you
maybe I'll tell you one day listen the
work speaks for itself good luck tonight
and have so much fun good to see you
[Music]